we are one week away from the
inauguration of President Donald and
according to new Quinnipiac University
Polling Donald Trump's approval rating
on his way into office thirty-seven
percent oh that's normal say the
trumpets he hasn't even done anything
yet blah blah blah blah blah wrong to
quote Donald Trump not only do some
presidents never get as low as 37
percent in their entire presidencies
typically they are way higher before
inauguration having just been elected
and riding high on the emotion and
inspired supporters each of the last
three presidents president obama george
w bush and Bill Clinton had approval
ratings of at least sixty-five percent
during their presidential transitions
also some interesting numbers from the
poll if the two percent say that Donald
Trump will be a not so good president
fifty-three percent don't believe that
Donald Trump is honest and fifty-two
percent say that Donald Trump does not
care about the average American these
aren't good numbers if you're not even
the president yet and this is already
what people think about you yeah the
question that comes to my mind was how
much better or worse would Hillary
Clinton's numbers be in this position
because there were so many things in her
closet so many scandals in her past but
I don't think she would continue to
shoot herself in the foot as much a drum
was doing now I think if Hillary Clinton
had one she would have had a completely
uneventful transition period from
November ninth until january twentieth
and it would not have been scandal after
scandal foot in mouth after foot and
mouth but this brings up a really
interesting situation within the
Republican Party which is that right now
most Republicans I know Marco Rubio
hammered Rex Tillerson at the hearing
the day before yesterday and you've got
some John McCain is now involved having
presented this 35 page document to to
the FBI but Republicans are mostly
playing nice because they want to be in
with Trump but lots of them we know
don't really like Donald Trump and
instead of rising if Trump's approval
stays in the mid 30's or even starts to
drop after he's inaugurated you can be
sure that Republicans are going to bail
on the Trump train and start talking
about conflicts of interest and the
emoluments Clause etc because they're
not going to want to lose re-election in
2018 if
Trump doesn't do well during 2017
Republicans will start to distance
themselves yeah they're going to have to
take into account what's politically
beneficial for them if Trump's approval
numbers are that low they're going to
distance themselves from him and Trump
may not even run for reelection in that
case george w bush's lowest approval
rating was 25 Trump is starting at 37
before he's even sworn in this is
historically bad and absent from press
coverage about Donald Trump is that his
agenda is not popular when you actually
pull people about the specifics of what
he wants to do people aren't loving a
lot of the things that he's proposing to
do my question is will the Rust Belt
voters and the others that were
responsible for pushing Trump over the
edge to electoral victory will they hold
them accountable when they realize
they'd been told a bunch of Lies and
that they were the proverbial cucks or
will they still approve of him because
if you bought it you own it and you
don't change horses midstream or
whatever other bogus an allergy you want
to news or will they say you know what
Trump cooked me and I'm now against
Trump yeah I mean it just goes to the
idea that will trump lose voters if I
use someone on Fifth Avenue I mean I
don't know if we can answer that at this
point I wonder if he will some day just
for kicks shoot someone on Fifth Avenue
to prove that he wouldn't lose voters
it's also important to point out that he
lost the popular vote by nearly three
million vote yeah so of course he's not
going to have even close to a majority
of people supporting him yet there are
millions more people in the country who
voted for someone other than Trump
thanks for watching this video before
you watch the next one remember we're
raising money to expand the David Pakman
show big league as well as expand
progressive activism go to david
pakman.com slash donate donations of any
size are much appreciated